temps des fêtes vers aux déchets est ce
que c'est possible le bain le défi
semble colossal parce qu uniquement par
rapport à noël on nous dit que les
canadiens jette plus de 540 mille tonnes
de papier d'emballage donc ça c'est bon
pour l'année au complet mais on s'entend
quand une bonne partie qui se passe
durant le temps des fêtes alors avec
nous pour poursuivre cette discussion
marc olivier bonjour déçu olivier
bonjour bon professeur chercheur au
centre de transfert technologique en
écologie industrielle de l'université de
sherbrooke
c'est bien ça c'est long un peu on
aurait pu la fourrure mais elle subit
dites nous à monsieur olivier le temps
des fêtes poursuit c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des emballages cadeaux
mais il ya la décoration la vaisselle en
styromousse
est ce que c'est possible d'adopter des
comportements verts durant le temps des
fêtes
ben non seulement c'est possible je
dirais même que c'est essentiel que ont
créé un déclic dans notre société on est
en pleine période de grands changements
présentement venaient tous entendu
parler de des objets à usage unique du
bannissement que l'on veut mettre en
place
on a commencé avec des sacs de plastique
les sacs d'épicerie qui était trop mince
qui était pas durable on va continuer
avec tous les petits objets de plastique
qu'on retrouve échouées sur les plages
qu'on retrouvait jouer chaud ici et là
en bordure de rue mais il faut aussi
qu'on aille plus loin dans les objets à
usage unique beyou tous les emballages
ce que traditionnellement on utilise
pour chercher un cadeau mais pourquoi on
a besoin de cacher un cadeau avait en
achetant des papiers parfois même un peu
dispendieux lorsqu'on a besoin de se
satisfaire nous même d'avoir du plus
joli papier est ce que ces deux voisins
gonflables le papier que j'utilisais
plume aux chrétiens ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose comme ça là il faudrait
qu'on revienne vers autre chose pas si
on recycler sa patrie sont recyclables
d'autres non et c'est là qu'il faut bien
faire la nuance
lorsque vous avez des papiers
d'emballage qui sont des papiers
régulier oui c'est du papier oui ça se
recycle mais si vous avez des papiers
d'emballage qui sont fortement métallisé
en rails là c'est la catastrophe on
n'est pas capable de recycler des
papiers fortement métallisé ça veut dire
qu'ils savent à prendre le chemin des
déchets ultimes
si vous avez des rues ben si vous avez
des cordes les attaches qui servent pour
ces cadeaux là on peut pas mettre dans
un bac de récup ne plus arriver dans un
centre de tri toujours s'empêtrer dans
les équipements qui ont déterminé qu'il
faut pas les mettre là il faut les
mettre du côté des déchets alors on s'en
vont vers quoi je pense qu'on s'en va
vers une société où on doit d'abord où
est au départ il faut repenser le cadeau
lui même et cette immense société de
consommation avec des équipements qui
sont en obsolescence programmée mais il
faut surtout surtout surtout repenser
les emballages cadeaux at on besoin de
ces formats d'emballage cadeau vous avez
tous entendu parler d'un mouvement qui
suggère d'avoir des objets réemployables
emballages
je connais des gens qui utilisent des
loges avaient fait occulter lisent des
coupons de tissus parfois même coloré
joliment décorée comme étant la façon
d'emballer un cadeau et que ça serve
encore chez nous on a aussi commencé à
utiliser des sacs à dos les sacs cadeaux
que l'on vaut tout simplement des sacs à
dos qu'on s'est procurées ya quelques
années et qu'on peut ressortir année
après année on récupère d'une amie lola
qu'on peut faire compliqué on veut faire
du réemploi d'une année à l'autre donc d
exemple on peut se servir de ça
lorsqu'on va arriver pour le réveillon
du jour de l'an
petit cadeau à l'hôtesse généralement ce
qu'on fait mais là il ya aussi tous ces
emballages de styromousse ont fait
affaire avec des traiteurs on voit
arriver des pelotes plastique à qui
parfois ne sont même pas recyclables non
plus n'ont pas ce qu'on fait mais vous
d'autres conseils pour les oui j'ai
d'autres conseils pour vous aider là
dessus d'abord you les plots des
traiteurs meilleur nos propres peurs nos
propres achats
si vous avez à recevoir 20 à 30
personnes et que vous n'avez pas la
vaisselle en dur pour recevoir tous ces
gens là il fut tintin il ya une dizaine
d'années une vingtaine d'années où on se
procurait des assiettes
plastiques jetables qu'on utilise une
seule fois et où on s'est passé ça c'est
d'autres fois il ne faut plus faire ce
truc là on s'en rend bien compte que si
vous avez à recevoir des gens ne pas
utiliser des assiettes qui ne serviront
qu'une seule fois et qui à présent vont
aller du côté de la poubelle ça va pas
c'est pas comme ça que j'étais
maintenant donc vous allez prendre quoi
d'une assiette en carton tout
mollassonne si les gens que vous recevez
ce sont des gens qui vous tiennent à
coeur
peut-être que c'est mieux de poids les
recevoir dans une assiette en carton
vous pouvez vous procurer quelques
assiettes supplémentaire de porcelaine
dans un centre de réemploi ce sera des
assiettes des paris mais localisation
vos assiettes de placer vos assiettes de
cartons c'était aussi des assiettes
dépareillé vaut mieux penser à des
objets qui peuvent être réemployés qui
peuvent être durables d'une année à
l'autre
et après ça on va être coincé vous me
dites avec les plots des traiteurs ben
on a eu un traiteur l'an dernier en
quarts qui nous a apporté des choses
c'était dans des plats d'aluminium
mouler la première chose que j'ai fait
j'ai bien tenté de récupérer ces plots
de lire l'avis de les conserver et j'ai
pu même pu m'en servir durant l'été on
faisait des barbus qui vous en avez
besoin de plomb aluminium pour être
capable donc de manipuler les chats ou
au barbecue magie ressorti les vieux
plats qu'on avait reçu du traiteur
c'était plutôt que d'en faire qu'une
seule fois et de les mettre parce qu'ils
étaient en aluminium de les mettre
directement à la récup
je les ai lavé je les ai conservé pour
faire du réemploi
mais c'est certain que si vous achetez
des choses dans des plats en styromousse
à bâle on est encore coincé parce que le
styromousse et le mal aimé de nos
plastique on attend toujours
l'autorisation
de nos municipalités pour faire de la
récupération du styromousse
on nous dit que ça va arriver ça fait
deux ans qu'on nous dit il pour du
styromousse on refait de styromousse
voilà dans la composition de ce que oui
voilà c'est parce que le styromousse et
un polystyrène le polystyrène si on le
reprend on est capable de faire d'autres
objets de polystyrène vous connaissez
tous les règles de 15 cm de 30
centimètres que nos enfants utilisent à
l'école ces petites règles transparentes
ils sont faits de polystyrène n'ont pas
de polystyrène expansé mais de
polystyrène de récupération qu'on à
faire fondre pour lesquelles on a moulé
des règles ça vient aussi des plats de
sirop moss parce que c'est du
polystyrène c'est la même nature c'est
pas la même texture c'est la même nature
fait que tout se peut se faire alors on
atteint ce peut-être comme on dit dans
le souhait d'une nouvelle 1 peut être
qu'on pourrait passer le message à
nogent à la qui s'occupe de direction
nos villes de durex occupent des
matières résiduelles
allez vous vous décidez à autoriser
qu'on mette tous nos bureaux nos
morceaux de plots de 6 bronze dans une
récupération pour pouvoir fabriquer des
règles pour ne serait-ce que ce soit
pour nos enfants à l'école y abonner de
trucs comme ça qu'ils peuvent être
améliorées pour et j'espère bien que
pour l'année à venir
tous nous allons regarder ce que nous
devons jeter maintenant et nous devons
aussi prendre une résolution la
résolution que lille et noël prochain
on n'est plus à faire ça monsieur
olivier le temps file
on va devoir s'arrêter ici merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous voir en ce
temps des fêtes et on va souhaiter un
temps des fêtes zéro déchet ou presque
les efforts ou presque zéro déchet et
puis qu'est ce que vous allez faire avec
vos cartes de noël qu'est-ce que vous
êtes faire avec les guirlandes défraîchi
avec les jeux de lumière qui refusent
d'allumer avec vos vieux sapins de noël
artificiel
il faut un jour qu'on discute de tout
seul on le refera on va évitera nouveau
merci beaucoup monsieur marc ollivier
dans le professeur à l'université de
sherbrooke
et puis voilà et puis bonne continuation
du temps des fêtes à tous merci